- [Instructor] Talk about the main types
of statistical studies.
So you can have a sample study
and we've already talked
about this in several videos
but we'll go over it again in this one.
You can have an observational
study, observational study.
Or you can have an experiment, experiment.
So let's go through each of these
and always pause this
video and see if you can
think about what these words likely mean,
or you might already know.
Well, sample study, we have looked at.
This is really where
you're trying to estimate
the value of a parameter for a population.
So what's an example of that?
So let's say we take the
population of people in a city,
and so that could be hundreds
of thousands of people,
and the parameter that you care about is
how much time on average do
they spend on a computer.
So the parameter would be
for the entire population.
If it was possible, you
would go talk to every,
maybe there's a million
people in the city.
You would talk to all
million of those people
and ask them how much time
they spend on a computer
and you would get the average
and then that would be the parameter.
So population parameter,
population parameter,
would be average time
on a computer per day,
average daily time, time on a computer.
Now you'd determine that it's impractical
to go talk to everyone, so
you're not going to be able
to figure out the exact
population parameter,
average daily time on a computer,
so instead, you do a sample study.
You randomly sample, and
there's a lot of thought
in thinking about whether
your sample is truly random,
so you randomly sample and there's also
different techniques of randomly sampling.
So you randomly sample
people from your population
and then you take the average
daily time on a computer
for your sample, and that
is going to be an estimate
for the population parameter.
So that's your classic sample study.
Now in an observational study,
you're not trying to estimate a parameter.
You're trying to understand
how two parameters
in a population might
move together or not.
So let's say that you
have a population now,
so let's say you have a population of,
let's say you have a
population of 1,000 people.
1,000 people, and you're
curious about whether
average daily time on a computer,
how it relates to people's blood pressure.
So average computer time,
oh, I shouldn't be writing this way.
Instead of average computer time,
it should just be computer time.
Computer time versus blood
pressure, blood pressure.
So what you do is you apply
a survey to all 1,000 people
and you ask them how much
time you spend on a computer
and what is your blood pressure?
Or maybe you measure it in some way,
and then you plot it
all, you look at the data
and you see if those two
variables move together.
So what does that mean?
Well, let me draw.
If this axis is, let's
say this is computer time.
Computer time, and this
axis is blood pressure.
Blood pressure.
So let's say that there's one person
who doesn't spend a lot
of time on a computer
and they have a relatively
low blood pressure.
There's another person
who spends a lot of time,
has high blood pressure.
There could be someone who
doesn't spend much time
on a computer but has a
reasonably high blood pressure,
but you keep doing this and
you get all these data points
for those 1,000 people, and
I'm not going to sit here
and draw 1,000 points, but
you see something like this,
and so you see, hey, look, it looks like
there's definitely some outliers
but it looks like these two
variables move together.
It looks like, in general,
the more computer time,
the higher the blood pressure,
or the higher the blood
pressure, the more computer time.
And so you can make a conclusion here
about these two variables correlating,
that they're positively correlated.
There is a positive, a
reasonable conclusion
if you did the study
appropriately would be
that more computer time correlates
with higher blood pressure
or that higher blood pressure correlates
with more computer time.
Now, when you do these
observational studies
or when you interpret these
observational studies,
when you read someone
else's, it's very important
not to say oh, well, this shows me
that computer time causes blood pressure,
because this is not showing causality,
and you also can't say,
maybe you might say,
somehow blood pressure causes more people
to spend time in front of a computer.
That seems even a little bit sillier,
but they're actually the same
'cause all you're saying is
that there's a correlation.
These two variables move together.
You can't make a
conclusion about causality,
that computer time causes blood pressure
or that high blood pressure
causes more computer time.
Why can't you make that?
Well, there could be what's
called a confounding variable,
sometimes called a lurking variable,
where let's say that, so
this is computer time.
Computer time, and this is blood pressure.
Looks like building, so
blood, blood pressure.
And it looks like these
two things move together.
We saw that right over here in our data,
but there could be a root variable
that drives both of these,
a confounding variable,
and that could just be the amount
of physical activity someone has.
So there could just be a
lack of physical activity
driving both, lack of activity.
People who are less active spend
more time in front of a computer,
and people who are less active
have higher blood pressure,
and if you were to control for this,
if you were to take a bunch of people
who had a similar lack of activity
or had a similar level of activity,
you might see that computer time
does not correlate with blood pressure,
that these are just both
driven by the same thing
and what you're really
seeing here is like, okay,
people who aren't active
drives both of these variables.
So once again, when you do
this observational study
and if you do it well,
you can draw correlations
and that might give you decent
hypotheses for causality,
but this does not show causality
because you could have
these confounding variables.
Now, experiments, and experiments are
the basis of the scientific method.
Experiments are all about
trying to establish causality,
and so what you would do is
if you wanted to do an
experiment, you would take,
and you probably wouldn't be able
to do it with 1,000 people.
Experiments in some ways are
the hardest to do of all of these.
Maybe you take 100 people, 100 people,
and to avoid having this
confounding variable
introduce error into your experiment,
you randomly assign these
hundred people to two groups.
So random assign, it's very important
that they're randomly assigned.
And that's nice, you might not know
all of the confounding variables there,
but it makes it likely
that each group will have
a same amount of people
with lack of activity
or the activity levels on
average in each of the groups,
when they're randomly assigned,
it gives you a better chance
that one group doesn't have
a significantly different
activity level than the other.
And then what you do is you have
a control group and you
have a treatment group.
Once again, you've randomly assigned them.
So a control and then treatment.
And what you might say is, okay,
for some amount of time, all
of you in the control group
can only spend max of 30
minutes in front of a computer,
or maybe if you really
wanted to do it, you'd say
you have to spend exactly
30 minutes on a computer
and that's maybe a little unrealistic,
and then the treatment
group, you have to say,
you have to spend exactly two
hours in front of a computer,
and I'm making up these numbers at random,
and it would be nice to see, okay,
what as everyone's blood
pressure before the experiment?
And you'd say, okay, well,
the averages are similar
going into the experiment,
and then you go some amount of time
and you measure blood pressure,
and if you see that, wow, this group
definitely has a higher blood pressure,
this group has a higher blood pressure,
so the blood pressure is higher here,
and once again, some of this might have
just happened randomly, it
might've been the people
you happened to put in
there, et cetera, et cetera,
but depending if this was
a large enough experiment
and you conducted it well,
this says, hey, look,
I'm feeling like there
is a causality here,
that by making these
people spend more time
in front of a computer,
that that actually raised
their blood pressure.
So once again, sample study,
you're trying to estimate
a population parameter.
Observation study, you are
seeing if there is a correlation
between two things and
you have to be careful
not to say, hey, one is causing the other
'cause you could have
confounding variables.
Experiment, you're trying to establish
or show causality and you do
that by taking your group,
randomly assigning to
a control or treatment.
That should evenly or
hopefully evenly distribute.
Not always, there's
some chance it doesn't,
but distribute the confounding variables
and then on each group,
you change how much
of one of these variables they get
and you see if it drives
the other variable.
So anyway, in the next two videos,
we'll do some examples of identifying
these types of sample studies
and thinking about what
we can conclude from them,
or these types of statistical studies
and see what we can conclude from them.